what is Chris Evans known for he's he's
very known for schmapped in America
what is Chris Evans favorite food his
favorite food jelly beans jelly beans
jelly beans I don't know if we're
categorizing that as food but I eat them
uh what is Chris evans's first movie
well technically it's Not Another Teen
Movie I mean I did a couple of little
things back in Massachusetts but I don't
think anyone wants to call them actually
wait before we go to the next one what
was your first one yeah well the first
movie the official movie was a movie
called the newcomers yes
what is Chris Evans like in real life
well he's very huggable he's very very
huggable look at that look at that and
he's also filled with jelly beans
that's a true fact